Je considère le handicap comme si j'étais
handicapé par conception, ce n'est pas la
maladie des motoneurones qui m'a fait dire à la fois que c'est
la conception des choses lorsque les gens
créaient des expériences ou des produits auxquels ils
ne pensaient pas au handicap au
début il n'y a pas huit ans et  mes
bras ont commencé à se paralyser lentement et
sont maintenant complètement paralysés les deux mains
dans les deux bras les personnes handicapées
sont les hackers d'origine
m'habiller et c'est
comme ça que je l'ai fait chez moi et il
n'y avait pas vraiment de vêtements à la mode il y a
huit ans quand je suis devenu
handicapé, donc j'étais un
co-fondateur en retard d'une incroyable organisation à but non lucratif basée
ici à New York appelée style ouvert  lab,
nous créons des appareils portables pour que les gens
s'habillent facilement qui sont également
à la mode et le manteau m'a été très
utile, il me permet de glisser ma
tête car ils ont mis du
désossage de poisson qui est un type de matériau de mode similaire
dans le cou et je peux  glisser
à droite et ils ont un beau
manteau noir avec mon équipe j'ai créé un collier lecteur de carte de métro
où j'ai mis le
lecteur de carte de métro dans l'attache du
collier j'ai mis mon cou vers le bas et je l'ai déplacé
sur le côté et il balaie le métro
[  Musique]
une personne sur cinq dans le monde a un
handicap permanent et ils ont de l'argent, c'est
la grande chose que les marques ne
réalisent pas que la communauté des personnes handicapées a un
revenu disponible de huit mille milliards de
dollars, ce qui est énorme, mais il n'y a vraiment que
quelques marques qui
y pensent  créer des produits et de la publicité
qui représentent un cinquième du monde
lorsque vous concevez pour les cas extrêmes, vous
créez un meilleur design dans des cas comme
celui-ci avec un écran tactile,
des voitures autonomes, des coupures de trottoir et la machine à écrire, ce
sont toutes des inventions qui ont été créées
pour quelqu'un avec  un handicap mais ce sont
juste de meilleurs designs et maintenant utilisés par tous
et je suis allé voir quelques
créateurs de mode très célèbres, vous pouvez penser
aux cinq meilleurs créateurs de mariée et
beaucoup d'entre eux ont dit non, nous n'allons pas ajouter de
poches au stress, ils ne
modifieraient pas la robe de sa forme originale
même si je  vous en aviez besoin pour la
recherche en santé vous êtes sur les réseaux sociaux et vous
voyez une annonce avec une personne
handicapée et vous avez l'impression qu'elle
représente la communauté bien aimée
partagez-la commentez-la parce que cet
engagement l'amène à plus de gens Je
pense que c'est vraiment un  petite chose, je
pense qu'il est très important d'acheter auprès de marques qui soutiennent
les personnes handicapées
et si vous travaillez dans un
rôle de cratère en vous assurant que les personnes
handicapées sont représentées dans les publicités
que vous créez, la partie la plus difficile pour moi
de devenir handicapée n'était pas que je
pouvais  Je ne fais pas physiquement quelque chose, c'était
les idées préconçues que
les gens avaient sur le handicap, c'est
que les médias et les marques ne
montrent pas les personnes handicapées et
quand ils le font, ils les montrent d'une
manière très triste, mais j'aime ma vie,
je ne changerais pas.  c'est pour le
monde